Josh Duhamel accidentally caught
undressing Justin Bieber and Haley
Baldwin are heating up the Big Apple
while we're heating up the grill in time
for the 4th of July everybody I'm Denny
direct oh this is the daily Denny and
we're getting the fourth of July started
early with some tips on how to amp up
your backyard barbecue but first some
fireworks Hollywood style we have the
stars who are going to celebrate
Independence Day with red hot new
romances including new couple josh
duhamel and Aissa gonzalez who are
flaunting their beach bods while
vacationing in Mexico but you know fans
got a glimpse of a whole lot more after
Josh was accidentally caught undressing
for the whole world to see
yeah it happened I used to share this
video to Instagram and what started as a
moment showing off her bikini body
turned into her giving up the goods on
her guy stripping instead cuz if you
look closely the 28 year old baby
drivers star isn't selfie mold and you
can see Josh's reflection in the door
caught as he's pulling down his board
shorts funny enough I used to who failed
to acknowledge Josh's chiseled physique
caps in the clip feel comfortable in
your own skin and I'd say the cup was
pretty comfortable in fact a source
revealed eet josh and i isa
who have been romantically linked since
february are quote head over heels for
one another the same could be said for
Justin Bieber and Haley Baldwin who a
source says are casually dating after
rekindling their romance in recent weeks
well these two seem to be having a blast
in the Big Apple because over the
weekend they were spotted making out in
a garden in Brooklyn seemingly paying no
mind to the paparazzi who caught the
mid-block on Sunday Justin and Haley
were seen enjoying a healthy lunch date
at whoo kitchen and I witnessed lzt
their interactions were flirty and they
looked very happy even taking pictures
with some fans one of those lucky fans
was Kendall Rivera who shared this
selfie she and her pal snapped at the
lovebirds with et she tells us the
couple was so nice and immediately
wanted to have a conversation
alright guys moving on now because
tomorrow is the 4th of July
and what's Independence Day without some
festive treats and some good eats am i
right that's why I brought on our
lifestyle Queen
you the chrissy teigen of chicago was
Holly Stevens good girl ultimate
compliment you are too sweet well look
at the spread you know fourth of July we
got to go big barbecue time yeah why
what do you got for us so you know what
the holidays it's a busy time fourth of
July's in the middle of the week so I
thought let's make it simple let's do a
create and build your own hotdog station
you can put out all these different
condiments whatever you like whatever
wild I mean peanut butter nuts I say the
wild are the better I have five here and
I thought it might be fun to have you
build them probably to work all right
let's do it starting with the Chicago
dog I'm from Chicago I'm Chicago
loyalists I only do a dog Chicago style
so grab your hot dog let's put on some
green relish yeah I do logo I mean this
pickled mustard but no ketchup guys this
is very important no ketchup no that is
like a sin in Chicago like the opposite
yes you will get yelled at kindly
because we're very nice in Chicago
did you see only Neal duck so next one a
little celery salt
it's deliciousness and I don't know what
else anyone uses it for other than this
so next you want a pickle spear yeah
very important on a Chicago dog you did
yep then you want to get some tomato
wedges in there coral color yeah yeah we
do it big in Chicago yeah we do okay now
you want sport peppers they're spicy
oh yeah I like so good yes do it okay
now you need a little onion white onion
that's it looks delicious
yep okay next one you're gonna do a
Frito pie dog so you're gonna yeah so
put a little chili on there get after it
nice and meaty and like you can either
make your own chili yeah pan chili so
you want a little cheese the cheddar
cheese is right here yep get after it
awesome and then it wouldn't be a Frito
pie without some free to go so get those
Fritos in there any corn chip will do
really awesome all right so then some
green onion oh yeah you did a lot of
Fritos I like that about you you know
what I'm hungry
all you need is a little sour cream and
you're done with that one
yes Oh Chicago Chicago like I literally
don't I don't do a hotdog any other way
okay next one we're gonna do a bond me
hot dog okay which is a little spin on
the you know Bonnie sandwich so cucumber
yup cucumber and you're gonna do a
little pickled carrot okay now a little
jalapeno for some spice yep and then
you're gonna want some peanuts beautiful
you are
now we're doing a Hawaiian dog so get
your grill I know me well but let's
start with some grilled pineapple yep
YUM I love a grilled pineapple yeah okay
so now you want a little jalapeno so you
were on it oh yeah I think so okay a
little red onion yeah I know you wanna
teriyaki Mayo material which is really
just mayo and teriyaki sauce look how
pretty does our staff but we have one
more right yes one more and this is
going to be the Mexican dog I'm a
feeling you're gonna want to eat this
one so is it cuz I'm Mexican hell um I
just knows all right well this one
you're gonna need avocados so I'm gonna
go ahead and cut this for you you're
also gonna want a little queso fresco
yeah so get yeah so much cheese now
you're also gonna want jalapeno okay a
lot of these have jalapeno I do okay
next we're gonna want some salsa which
is right there I should have done that
well yeah it's fine you're moving along
and then you're gonna want some red
onion so colorful okay a little cilantro
yes oh my gosh me too
it's very hit-or-miss and then the best
part strip holding yeah give me that
chapolin yeah let's see if you can do it
make it pretty
okay make it pretty yay okay all right
this one I'll air thank you this looks
so good
get after it so myself
YUM yeah okay good all right good
it's not a hot dogs but you you have to
have a dessert and yeah you do end on
the jalapeno oh yeah and I'm thinking
it's Morse nothing say you know campfire
fourth of July like a s'more tomorrow
yeah I just thought little kids have it
ready for people so grab and go hit the
campfire the bonfire the grill grill
yeah girl it's more I'm down now you
guys cannot a structure fourth of July
oh right
hot dog bar well you need to do it no
big bro yeah any time I love it
all right guys so guess what I'm gonna
go enjoy the holidays
yeah won't happen show the rest of this
week and we'll be back on Monday though
with a brand new Danny Danny so of
course make sure you're subscribed to
our YouTube channel following us on
Facebook watch I'll see you guys back on
Monday I'm gonna go lay out by the pool
be tan you need hot bag or five I'm
gonna five my holiday are you guys happy
for bye